okay I call that celebration what is up
everybody Persia here and the name of
today's game is gonna be a valence but
before we go any further we've got some
heavy hitters in the lobby right now
phrase thanks first Brandon from Riot
Games is joining us hello we also got a
tubby all the way from the UK hey great
to be joining you guys this game can run
on all different types of computers and
laptops but I'm gonna kick it over to
Brandon so he can get into all those
details that's right we really wanted to
make sure that Balor is accessible to a
wide range of players that really means
taking special care to optimize the game
both for high-end machines but also for
older and low-end machines which i think
is amazing because my laptop that we're
gonna be playing on later is a complete
potato I've done some of my best gaming
on potatoes all right so you have to
curious in the second game I reign all
the way from London okay yeah yeah my
shoulders already luckily we get to kick
things off on the high end setups first
you know get that warm up in I think we
just need to jump into it guys let's get
into it so I'm running this on my
high-end gains machine at the moment I'm
and so far like games once like silky
silky smooth and I think I probably hit
I think it speaks somewhere around maybe
like the 400 frames mark which is
obviously like it's way higher than any
monitor you're ever gonna get this can
be
I pranked everything up to full and
being able to get the game to dip below
about 150 yet
this game really really to try to make
the game run for like the competitive
atmosphere where you just have a bunch
of frames and like if you have the
hunger to run it you shouldn't really
like notice a dip below what your
monitor should support so I really have
everything turned up all the way to the
max right now we might win this one our
high end game it's in the books but what
I'm really excited to see is how our low
end setups you know how they do because
this laptop that I'm gonna be playing on
which I've set up which I've connected
to this monitor for you know I need some
luxury alright this laptop this is
stressful because I can't record the
gameplay while I'm playing it is just
just the game so that's how low end my
laptop is I got a whopping 68 frames in
the firing range said what are you
working with 68 frames is not bad
running on an old laptop I'm impressed
you had potato before I have a 10 year
old spud that was left in some like
Accountant of its floor that they just
didn't want it's a 2 core three
gigahertz CPU I think we've got about 4
gigs of ram going on in here and it's it
is a one gigabyte graphics card vram
like ddr3 it's old school I checked it
out it came out like when I was much
much more youthful at Brandon what are
you bringing to the table in this
low-end Tex this machine is really just
like a 2.4 or 2.5 gigahertz machine dual
core four gigs of ram there's no actual
discrete graphics card in it it's the
integrated graphics card and this cpu is
maybe like eight years old so it is like
a piece of work actually and you can
kind of see it in the background it's
not the prettiest thing but we'll see
we'll see where it goes alright you guys
enough with all the tech talk it's time
to hop right into the match so potato
squad lets a symbol after assembling
that PCM in time be ready to assemble
this up I'm loving that like Phoenix
just looks basically the same he's
looking sharp for a for a guy who's
suddenly 10 years younger I see 10 years
older no he's 10 years older we actually
took like a pretty interesting approach
on scaling down everything for different
specs characters environments and and
weapons all take off different features
depending on like what they are so four
characters we try to make it so like you
know there that we retain a lot of the
like skin stuff and for guns
they still seem shiny and all that it's
a really interesting thing so like
almost Mike you shouldn't it shouldn't
be that much worse all I know is I am
already astonished at this laptop is
even running this right now because it
can't do much so farm I'm just amazed
that the the frames per second is these
like so consistent this game's laid in
I've seen a couple of dips here now you
like major combat but you know I've had
a hit at peak of 82 it's a little bit
more satisfying winning by killing
someone at a lower frame rate and let's
get it you got this this is easy I
really wanted to ask you about when you
guys were thinking about developing this
game was the priority to make a game
that would run on all the systems or
where you just was it a byproduct of
making a game that fit the particular
art style that you've gone for
intolerant performance all across the
board was definitely really important
especially on the high end machines for
the competitive aspect as many things as
we can get but and it's not really a
byproduct but it's kind of like along
those lines we wanted to make the game
run on a wide range of hardware and kind
of get as many people who wanted to play
the game playing the game so what that
really means is like yeah you don't need
the nicest computer to run this and that
swings all across the board on every
speck of hardware and that just makes it
so like our low spec can play the game
at like a decently like acceptable frame
rate all right you guys we did it we
played one game of Valerie
on a high-end PC we played one game of
veteran on a low-end potato my poor
laptop but we did it we succeeded and I
somehow played better on the potato than
I did my high-end PC you know what I did
as well so clearly there's a thing going
around all I know it's like I've clearly
got to start jamming some RGB into my
low-end machine because this is the one
I'm gonna keep playing the game on
clearly I work on this and I'm always
surprised at how well it runs on these
low end machines like I when you're in
the game it's just the game right so
that's that's what it felt like to me
exactly once you're in there and you're
worried for your life all the other
stuff kind of fades away but it was so
much fun thank you so much to Brandon
and said and Aaron and Ben for it
teaming up and trying out some fun
experiments here with our tech but for
you at home if you're feeling like your
tech can't stand up to the challenge
it's free-to-play
just give it a shot you might be just as
surprised as I was so go ahead and
download and learn more at play valiant
comm and until next time see you later
[Music]